4h30 mounira khaled et sa famille vivent
dans le quartier depuis moins d'un an et
l'association sportive et communautaire
du centre-sud est rapidement devenu leur
deuxième maison
ça rapporte qu'on n'est pas isolé aussi
il ya quelque chose qui se passe juste à
côté de nous et ça nous appartient
ça fait plaisir le centre offre plus
d'une centaine d'activités aux enfants
de tous âges
je viens souvent à la bibliothèque
seront vraiment souvent des fois je vais
ici pour nager aussi dans la piscine ou
pour des fois juste défend bien et si
c'est pour eux le soir bal enfin à peu
près quatre heures bah on vit ainsi que
des fois pour jouer à cache-cache des
services qui selon les porte-parole
yvon deschamps et judy ritter change des
vies un enfant ici peut rêver s'il voit
la bibliothèque et aux délits vie voit
des enfants et 6 ans vivent quelque
chose il ya quelqu'un de réglo et ça se
fait pourtant tout désigné créé en
quelques mois la mère de famille a vu
ses enfants s'épanouir autour de l'école
ils font leurs devoirs où ils ramènent
de voir ici soit la bibliothèque qui
fréquentent aussi tous les jours soit
qui viennent aussi pour voir qu'est ce
qui se passe comme activité les jeux de
société aussi l'association sportive et
communautaire du centre-sud a été fondée
en 1974 pour permettre aux jeunes du
quartier de jouer au hockey et au
baseball
peu importe les moyens financiers de
leurs parents ça c'est facile notre
mission on n'a jamais refusé d argent
parce que les paramètres d'âge aux fils
des ans le centre a élargi son offre de
loisirs en plus de partager ses
installations entre autres avec des
adultes atteints de déficience
intellectuelle
c'est un des moyens de se sentir en
forme et rien que dans la société parce
que souvent on les oublie mais c'est des
gens faire ma mère
[Musique]
aujourd'hui grâce aux cours porte parole
qui ont sollicité des donateurs
l'association a pu agrandir ses locaux
et se doter d'une nouveauté une salle
psychomotrice % des enfants qui sont
propres et aller à l'école quand ça
arrive à l'école à la maternelle que le
besoin de créer d'abscon motricité c'est
faire en sorte que les enfants mam n'est
plus développé des aptitudes que soit la
gabegie et que ce soit de l'exercice
physique on avait ça engendre par jour à
l'aide aux devoirs long pouvant
accueillir 150 50 de plus par jour 900
0,5
c'est fabuleux le nouveau centre est
aussi une source de fierté pour les
jeunes selon doudou wade
les enfants ils réalisent maintenant
quand terreur sacrée pas partout il ya
quelqu'un qui va s'en occuper d'eux au
ils sont pris en mai et on brise pas les
choses et pixel boobs alors ils ont
aussi veulent être bobby bras et entre
autres ils ont droit un sentiment de
fierté qui contribuera à leur donner des
ailes pour l'avenir ici valérie michaela
ben haddou canada montréal